Oh Well, we have to sing the better one Okay
What did you say about my brother
What was the thing that changes your pov F5.
F5?
I've always wanted a brother.
It's my brother.
Just like you.
So guys, today we're here to explore.
Look at this.
We're going to explore World's Adventure.
We know where we want to go.
Literally, we were originally going to do the Disney The Disney was a Disney World one.
And then, when I was looking at Minecraft DLC, I saw this.
Yeah, so we switched.
I was like, oh my god.
Wait, but what do you mean adventure mode?
Wait, there's quests?
Yeah, there's quests to unlock like, more worlds.
So I guess we go to sandbox and we can go straight to Simba.
But we do like, adventure with explore all the worlds.
I was gonna say, I don't wanna I mean, we can try one, maybe.
We'll do one adventure and then if it's bad, we'll just go straight to the one we really wanna go to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can do that.
Yeah, so...
I always have to go to...
Guys, if you're wondering why I have to tap the dressing room, for some reason for me, if I tap out, it kicks me out of the lobby.
So, this is my solution to that.
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know if everything is okay for us.
For me and Mint.
Alright, so...
Hello, hello, hello!
Hello, everybody!
But yes, if we finish this, we'll go to Disney World.
It's like our reward.
Oh, did you buy that one?
No, I didn't.
We didn't?
Well, I feel like we should both buy it just for the skin pack.
Unless you wanna be a furry to Disney World.
Alright, here we go.
I'm pressing the button.
I'm pressing it.
Woah!
Where are we?
Wait, we're in Alice in Wonderland!
Is this Alice?
No.
Wait, no.
Where are we?
I don't know.
I'm gonna jump.
You're gonna jump?
She's swimming!
Daya!
Can you...
You can't contain me!
Can you feel the love tonight?
What the hell did I just grab?
Oh, how odd.
A visitor.
Seems you found this little refugee.
It's been a while since anyone else has shown up.
It's quite exciting.
I'm sure you feel the same.
But anyway, you must be wondering about all this.
Lucky for you, you're speaking to me.
Sonia, while I lack in awakeness, I make up for it with knowledge.
To fill you in, this is the dream pavilion and it can lead you to all sorts of magical places you may or may not have seen before.
I hear they sometimes appear in your most treasured dreams.
The dream pavilion is a place of connection and records.
From here, you can always see what's happening.
You just need to know where to look.
However, if there's anything you need to know, don't hesitate to ask.
Oh my god, where am I?
Movie Bar Inn.
What is that?
Wait, I didn't want to use this.
What's going on?
Wait, oh, there's a library here.
What's happening?
The record book of dreams.
It will automatically journal all sorts of information.
Just flip through.
Oh, in addition to the pavilion and the side rooms, this realm has some places to explore as well.
You can find some goodies around, I think.
Not that cute one.
There's gems.
Gem shards.
Collecting them will store them here.
They will grant certain powers.
Oh, okay.
Wait, I have a compass.
This is the gem one.
It'll get you back here.
This is so elaborate.
But it needs to be powered up first with a handy map.
And this is the crystal compass.
It's a peculiar device with many different powers.
But it runs on gem shards, so you'll need to collect some first before you can use any of them.
That should be it.
Do take care out there, but I'm sure you can handle it.
You forgot the yawn.
Okay, I got the quest.
I'm a gem one.
I already have a key.
I'm gonna unlock something.
The wand, like, transports us to places.
Yeah, it said, like, do you want to return to the hub?
Oh my god, look at our map.
We have Snow White.
We got Alice in Wonderland.
Aladdin.
Activate to detect... What the fuck?
I can cross wide gaps to get temporary speed boosts to push heavy boxes.
Oh, we are too stupid for this.
We are...
Whoa!
Oh!
Where did you take us?
Who are
you?
Oh my god, you're twin!
Who is that?
Is that some kind of ostrich?
Zazu keeps going on about Nala and I being betrothed.
I can't marry her.
She's my best friend.
Ask them if they're an ostrich.
Don't mind him, but hey, look like you're nice.
You wanna play with us?
Yeah, I know where we can go.
Come on.
Wait, it better not be the water hole again.
No, it's not.
Uncle Scar told me about it.
Like, he told you about the elephant graveyard and we almost got eaten by hyenas?
That is different.
No one said it's forbidden.
Oh, he's a bad boy.
He's a bad boy.
Maybe we should ask Zazu.
Fine, let's go to Pride Rock.
You coming, new friend?
Alright.
Oh my god, look.
It's right over here.
Oh my god, there's Pride Rock.
Look, it looks a lot smaller.
Circle of life.
Where's the rest of the animals?
They ate them all.
I feel like, is that the forbidden graveyard over there?
I think so.
We gotta get the gems too.
Fuck Simba.
Oh my god, it's your friends!
Look at them!
Oh wait, three gems nearby before they disappear.
Collect near before they disappear again?
Oh my god, is this time?
There's no way.
There's over there.
I see them.
Where?
It's a blue gem.
Can I hit you?
I thought I turned TVB on.
You turned TVB on!
I tried!
Oh my god, Disney won't let us commit violence.
Yeah, we tried to turn TVB on.
I tried to turn TVB on.
Oh my god, there's zebras!
There's zebras!
Eat it, eat it!
A circle of life.
There's only like four of each animal.
It's Noah's Ark.
There's a really dead number.
It's Noah's Ark!
That's what happened in the aftermath.
The lions are too hungry.
I'm so hungry.
Wait, what's this?
Oh my gosh, it's an elephant!
Wait, is there also only four elephants?
They're so tiny.
They're really small.
Wait, there's Scar!
Oh my god, you're my hero!
Oh my god!
There he is!
What is he saying?
Read it.
I'm reading.
I wonder when my brother will next descend from on high to mingle with the commoners.
Oh, that's it?
That's all he's got to say?
I'll tear you!
My dad said I'll be king next!
Everybody look left!
Everybody look right!
Everybody look up!
Send in the spotlight!
Not yet!
Yeah, I am a nepo baby.
Oh my god, this elephant's climbing the tree.
I should turn down my music.
How's the audio, everybody?
Actual, like, original music, too, for this game.
I know!
That's crazy.
It's looking Minecraft.
It's like Minecraft version of...
What the hell is this?
Oh, it's a wildebeest!
That's gonna kill my dad!
Oh my god!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
That's the dad killer!
That thing killed my dad!
This is where I'm almost dying.
It looks like it needs to eat.
It's so skinny.
It's so starving.
How hungry are you?
Oh my gosh, wait!
Timon and Pumbaa gotta meet up.
Timon and Pumbaa's here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I gotta change my clothes real quick.
Alright, we're changing, everybody.
We're changing.
Alright, am I...?
Yes.
Wait, where are you?
I'm changing.
You're changing?
Oh, don't look, guys.
Don't look.
She's changing right now.
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
I'm in front of you.
Do you not see me?
Oh, I'm loaded.
Wait, let me...
Wait, where are you?
Turn around, turn around!
Do you not see me?
I'm invisible, too!
Where are you?
What a wonderful phrase.
Oh my god, the world of beasts is really freaking out behind me.
I'm right beside you.
Where are you?
Wait, do you actually...
Wait, let me change.
I'll change my skin.
I'll be Sans for a little bit.
So do you see me?
Do you see Sans?
Okay, do you see me now?
What a wonderful phrase.
Wait, wait, wait.
Look at me.
Look at me real quick.
Oh, are you gonna dab or something?
I'm gonna...
Wait, what's...
Dance, Timon, dance!
Let's go.
We should've been doing quests, but we're just out here.
We're just out here exploring.
Wait, there's a pathway over here.
Oh, we might be able to find an actual Timon and Pumba.
Yeah.
And then we'll kill them and take their roles.
We're skinwalkers.
Yeah.
Oh, I see them!
Oh my god, he's so tiny.
He's so tiny.
He's freaking out!
He's like, what the fuck?
Do you remember the old Lion King CD-ROM games?
Have you ever played them?
No, I didn't.
I think that has to be...
Hey, Timon, come here.
I found...
You know, you think it's a really juicy bug grub?
Pumba, are you nuts?
That's obviously a big two-legged aardvark.
Oh, they're talking about us!
An aardvark?
Yeah, everyone knows aardvarks only eat bugs so they're not dangerous.
Come on.
You voice Pumba, I'll voice Timon.
Okay.
Come on, let's approach, slowly.
Okay, I'll be quiet.
I'm not burping.
Sorry.
You have to!
And they've spotted us.
Oh my god, he's got attitude.
Wow, they look really brave and strong.
Oh, Timon, you don't think?
I guess he does.
What does that mean?
Shh!
If this is really the protector we were hoping for, we can't be too obvious.
First, we make friends.
With games?
Exactly.
Ahem.
Say, brave warrior.
Might you be up for some friendly competition?
Yeah!
Wanna catch some grub?
Are we in?
Should we do it?
I'm gonna look at the instructions first.
I looked at the instructions.
Whoa!
Wait, did you go in?
Yeah.
All persons search the part of the jungle to catch as many grub as they can.
But grubs can be tricky.
They may hide underneath logs, so you'll need to rustle.
And don't forget...
Oh my god, it's a competition.
Wait, are you fighting?
I see you!
That's not me!
I'm not even...
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, there's so...
There's so many taboos!
What is this?
Wait, how do I pick them up?
How do I pick them up?
Oh my god, he just ate them!
No, no, no, that's mine!
How do you pick them up?
I didn't read the instructions!
Uh, uh, uh...
I don't know!
I
got it!
We got five points!
We did it!
I think we're the worst version of Timon and Pova.
How do we...
These are like five Timons, though.
Like, what the hell?
Okay, let's read the instructions.
Okay, okay, okay.
Instructions.
Here are the rules.
You just click on the...
The hitbox is so fun!
I tried clicking!
Me too!
They just run up and get them.
Yeah, this is not fair.
Why are there five Timons?
I don't know.
It's like they're multiplying.
Also, didn't they want our help?
Why are they beating us?
Okay, I'm trying my best.
Okay.
Grab it!
I don't understand!
I can't grab him!
I'm trying!
I'm trying to grab him!
Let me grab him!
How did we get five points before?
I don't know how we got five points there.
I don't know.
How did we grab him?
I grabbed him one time!
It's not letting me!
Oh, it's right click!
It's right click.
Oh my god, I was...
Oh my god.
I got it.
Oh my god, I got him.
Wait, there was a guy here.
I like the actual Minecraft.
Oh my god.
We can do this!
We can beat them!
We're better!
The moment we beat them, we become Timon and Pumbaa.
Oh, okay.
We almost got it.
We figured it out.
That's right, we're Timon and Pumbaa now.
We're taking your skin now.
I did try right click earlier.
I don't know, probably the hitbox.
Yeah, probably the hitbox.
It's okay, we won.
We won!
Oh no.
You guys can go die now, so we'll be the new Timon and Pumbaa.
We're better.
We stand on two legs.
Wait, what did they want us to do?
They didn't say congratulations or anything.
Oh, no, they did.
They said it to me.
What the hell?
Also, my music died.
It was playing Minecraft music for a little bit.
And it just died on us.
Wait, I have other emotes?
Oh my god, what are emotes?
Oh my god, I want...
Wait, no, I have to pay for this, nevermind.
Wait, did you pay for your...
Did you pay for your dance emotes?
I don't think so.
Wait, how do you have...
I just have wave.
What's this?
I have figure skating.
I have...
I like the kick part.
Wait, hold on.
I want to see if you do it again.
Wait, no, not that.
Why do I have just regular Minecraft music playing?
Again!
Come on, go!
Shake that booty!
It looks like the Megan dance.
Oh my god, look at him go!
It's not fair, all I could do is clap.
This is not fair.
That sounds like a skill issue.
It's not fair.
I can't either pay for it or...
The clouds!
Wait, there's Transformers emotes?
Wait, what the fuck is the Transformer emote?
What do you mean by that?
It's like...
Okay, wait, I'm gonna buy this!
I'm gonna see!
I'll buy this and then I'll show you.
Oh my gosh, I'm back to normal.
Okay, okay, okay, wait, how do I...
How do I equip this?
Equip...
No, you gotta...
There's a whole Transformers DLC!
Okay, okay, okay, watch this.
Watch this, okay.
Okay, okay.
It's like, I need to see this too.
Okay, watch this.
It was worth it.
Woah!
Transformers!
More than meets the eye!
Wait, can you see the legs?
Yeah!
Where do you get the emotes?
Transformers.
You know when you press to change emotes?
And you scroll down?
There's a Transformers icon.
Wait, I don't even remember how I changed it.
There's a Tetris one!
Oh my god!
There's Mega Man?!
Oh, I see, I see!
You see the Transformer icon?
Optimus kick.
Wait, you're...
Yeah, mine is the...
You can still see his tail!
What the hell is this?
Oh my god!
There's so many...
Wait, there's...
Wait, there's an angry bird?
Angry bird!
There's Halo!
Anger management, this is so lame.
Wait, there's Spongebob!
Oh my god, there's Halo too!
Yeah!
Oh, superhero!
Wait, there's...
Oh my god, wait!
Wait, I just have enough!
I just have enough for this!
Okay, okay, okay.
Watch this, watch this.
Are you looking?
Hold on, hold on, I'm looking at my own emote.
Okay, okay, okay.
Do it, do it, do it.
Okay, watch this.
Naruto!
Gotta go fast!
Gotta go faster, faster, faster!
Does it actually make you run faster?
Try.
No, I can't.
I can't move while emoting.
I can just be like...
So you just run in place?
Hold on, I'm gonna buy one too.
Wait, not that.
Guys, which one should I get?
There's so many.
Pumba the Hedgehog.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I like how we're spending money in Minecraft.
I got these points for free, okay?
I'm sure you did.
Wait, they have Ben 10?
Wait, there's an actual anime run.
There's actual Naruto.
Oh my god.
They have Ben 10.
That's actually crazy.
There's so many.
Why the fuck do we play Java?
We could've had this.
Oh my god, there is anime.
Okay, but I prefer Sonic 1 more.
I don't understand.
What's the squirrel one?
The squirrel one?
Is that from Playing Dead?
What the fuck kind of show is this?
I don't know.
Wait, there's more pages?
No, the second page is just a little bit.
Oh, there's how to train your dragon here.
What does Ben 10 do?
Ben 10?
He does this like...
Oh, it's Ice Age!
The squirrel is Ice Age.
Posing like a hero.
What is this?
Dancing like...
Hakuna Matata.
Oh, there's Hakuna Matata.
There's just a T-pose.
Wait, why are there two different types of T-poses?
And one is more expensive than the other one.
Wait, what?
I think there's like common versions, and then there's rare versions, but this is literally the same thing.
Yeah, it's the same evil.
What's the difference?
I like the Tetris one.
There is a dab one.
Oh, there's Tetris one.
Yeah, where he's in the air.
The drop one?
What's going on here?
Tetris dance?
That's so good, wait.
I sort of want to buy this, but you spend $5.
I sort of want to be Tetris.
It's just so good.
It's so good.
There's like some really random ones.
Oh, I see the dab.
I see the dab.
Oh my god, I can make Puma do a dab.
Wait, bouncy ball?
He turns into a ball, I saw that, yeah.
There's one where...
Maybe there's the ones that we want, but cheaper.
Like, try and find ones that you want, but as a common.
I don't think I can find a Tetris one that's cheaper.
I don't...
No, the Tetris one is kind of insane.
Why doesn't...
Oh, Java.
I know Java, you can have a mod where you can add emotes and stuff, but like...
This is just better.
I think maybe free emotes would be better.
But like...
Can I be a Transformer?
Transformers, roll out.
Autobots, roll out.
Oh my god, it's dark!
Wait, what emote did you buy?
I didn't buy one.
I thought you were gonna buy one with your free coins.
Okay, I'll buy one with my free coins.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, do it.
Oh, somebody, thank you Kaz for the super chat for Tetris, thank you, it's worth it.
Wow.
That's the only thing I want.
The Tetris one was the only one I want.
Okay, let me...
Yeah, let me buy this.
Don't worry, it's worth it.
I tabbed out to buy Tetris.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm buying my Tetris emote.
Thank you guys for enabling me.
I really appreciate it.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm purchasing in progress.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
Let's do it together, you ready?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
3, 2, 1, go.
One more time, one more time.
Da da da...
Okay, we should progress the world.
Yeah, let's go do the world things now.
Wait, let's...
Are we doing the quest, or do we just want to explore...
area?
I think we could talk to them because they might have...
Oh, Simba and Nala?
We'll be like, sorry, we're too busy Tetrising.
We're definitely Timon and Pumbaa.
Yeah, we're your friends.
What a wonderful friends.
Do you think we can go to the little crevice that Simba died at?
Yeah, where Simba's dad died?
I think it's here.
I think it's literally here.
Oh my god!
Wait, we can recreate it!
Oh my god, we can recreate it!
Simba...
Wait, there's something over there.
Do you see it?
Oh my gosh, that's probably his soul.
Oh my god, is that dad?
You're not him anymore.
The gorge.
Oh, what's this?
You collected one collectible of this world.
Oh, is that my dad?
My dad's dead body?
Your dad's dead body.
What's that?
I can sense gem shards behind...
If only you could jump such a distance.
Oh, it's just to get gem shards.
Oh, so it's like my dad's soul I collected him.
He's just a collectible.
Wait, what if I jump here?
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is where we have to be able to jump.
Magic wand.
Do you want... oh wait, no, I don't want to return to hub.
How do I... magic...
What the hell is that?
Where are you?
Wait, is that another collectible?
That's what I thought, but it's actually a person.
Wait, oh, it's the hyena!
Yeah, you gotta get up from here.
Alright, what does he say?
Oh, he was a collectible!
Oh my god, we collected the hyena!
He's ours now.
He's our pet now.
Oh, shit, I was so close.
I got it.
Oh, parkour!
Okay, now I don't know what to do.
Okay, now I can't do the jump here.
I thought we were talking to Simba and Nala.
We're going, we're going.
I'm looking at the map.
Oh, it's on the other side.
Can you feel the love tonight, Timon?
I can see what's happening.
Some... I don't know.
Oh, there they are.
They fell in love with their lions.
Hello.
You can talk to him.
Alright, this is our home, Pride Rock.
And I'm gonna be the king someday.
Let's hurry up and find Zazu.
Where could he be?
Zazu.
Where's Zazu?
Oh, god, they're gone.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye.
Okay, we have to find Zazu.
Like, I'm looking at the map.
Zazu should be, like, right here.
Look, you see the exclamation point?
He's up here.
Wait, he's on Pride Rock?
Yeah.
Zazu, what are you doing up here?
That's for the monkey.
Oh, my gosh, there's lions in here.
Wait, wait, I wanna see.
Oh, it's Mufasa.
Look, I've never seen a creature like this around here.
Neither have I, Zazu, but they don't look like trouble.
Hello, I'm Mufasa.
Welcome to the- Wait, he's alive!
He hasn't died yet!
Are we gonna recreate their deaths?
Oh, my god.
We're gonna recreate their deaths.
Let's go!
I must ask, did my son bring you here?
He has a knack for surprises.
Speaking of your son, sire, I'd better have a look at what he and Nala are up to.
I don't have a good feeling about it.
You never do, Zazu.
We can find Simba outside Pride Rock.
Is that mom?
Oh, they don't wanna talk to us.
Oh, there's Rafiki's thing.
Alright, where is... It's like over there.
Oh, do we go to the elephant graveyard?
Oh, there they are!
I see them.
There you are, Zazu.
Can we go to the jungle, please?
The jungle?
Don't be ridiculous.
Do you have any idea how dangerous that would be?
It's outside the Pride Lands.
We're lions.
But Uncle Scar said there's nothing a lion would have to be afraid of there.
A grown lion, perhaps, but a cub?
I'm not so sure.
Come on, Zazu.
It'll be fun.
Besides, what could happen while you're with us?
I'm really not.
Hey, don't you dare run off!
Come back!
Sire, you're here!
Simba... Nala...
Mufasa just shows up, pops out, like...
Nala, where do you think you're going?
I told you leaving the Pride Lands would be dangerous.
What is he gonna say?
And you try to drag Zazu along with you?
I'm sorry, Dad.
I just thought it'd be fun.
It's only the jungle.
Simba...
You're too...
You're too young, and someday you will be king.
That is a very big responsibility, requiring you to be responsible.
I know, Dad.
I'm really sorry.
Well, I'm glad I caught you before anyone was hurt.
Now we're going home.
Sorry, we can't show you the jungle.
I bet it's really cool.
We can't show them, but maybe they can tell us what it's like.
Why do you... Oh my god, they talk so much.
It's already... The sun's out already.
I know!
Think about it.
They're not forbidden from leaving the Pride Lands.
They can go there and tell us about it.
Oh yeah!
Then we'll see how fun it'll be when we get there.
Of course, that'd be a long time when we're grown.
Then it's a plan.
Will you go to the jungle on a scouting mission for us?
You will?
Awesome!
Yes, I can.
Okay, okay.
I think...
I did it.
We already went to the jungle.
Do we have to do it again?
Let me show you something.
Come over here.
Okay.
Follow me.
Simba.
We gotta get the other three gems.
Collect two gems before they disappear again.
The baobab tree.
Oh, is this where Rafiki lives?
Oh my God, this is a tall-ass fucking tree.
Oh, there he is!
The weather is very particular, don't you think?
Oh, that's all you say?
That's all you say?
Wait, he said something else.
What'd he say?
Hardcore.
I tried to...
Something else popped up.
Did you guys see it?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Talk to him.
No, it didn't show up again after.
Maybe I clicked on you.
No?
I know who you are, but it's... Oh, he knows who we are.
What?
He knows who we are.
Oh, he's dancing!
Watch out, Rafiki!
Watch out!
You're gonna get Tetris!
I just wanna recreate Mufasa's death.
Maybe that's the end of the story.
Is he gonna die?
I thought he was gonna... I thought he was gonna grow up.
I mean, we have to go to the jungle.
Yeah, we gotta go to the jungle first.
Let's see if we can recreate his death first.
But usually they, like, disappear.
Let's go to the jungle and see if there's anything over there now.
Where did you go?
Towards the jungle.
Where are you?
I'm going to the jungle.
I'm following the pathway.
I see Scar.
I went the other way.
I was in front of Pride Rock.
Oh, okay.
So, I'm going... I'm looking at my map.
I have a map.
You know, we all have that map now.
I wonder if we can change the timeline.
Save him?
We can save Mufasa?
Save Mufasa!
Or we just kill Scar right now.
Where are you?
I'm heading to the jungle!
I'm literally in the jungle!
So am I!
I'm already here.
Me too!
No, you're not.
Yes, I am!
Oh, yeah, I see your name.
Somebody is a snowpoke.
I'm in the jungle.
Yeah, I'm next to them.
I don't think we need to talk to them again.
Yes, we do.
It's literally on the map.
Wait, is it?
Oh, wait, no, you're right.
Wait, what's the point of going here?
Wait, let's see...
I don't think there is anything else we need to do.
Okay, we have to find all the wild gems.
Yeah, no, these are collectibles.
Yeah, but then, like, why the fuck did...
I'm eating my book right now.
Who needs that read?
Reads for losers.
Reads for nerds.
We ain't no nerds.
Wait, does that mean we just have to talk to them again?
Talk to Simba again?
Simba, hurry up.
We wanna kill your dad.
What if we already did everything we need to do?
There's no way.
Except we have to find the collectibles and stuff.
There's no way Simba is supposed to grow up.
I'm pretty sure he's supposed to grow up.
We've explored the jungle.
No, we haven't actually.
In the jungle...
We gotta find the hidden hyenas.
Oh my God, this is kind of crazy.
Alright, I'm talking to Simba.
I bet I'm right.
Oh no, there's a stuck zebra.
There's a zebra.
Oh my God.
Alright, I'm talking to them.
Save him.
Let him die as a circle of life.
Okay.
This also keeps going on about Nala and I being betrothed.
I can't marry her, she's my best friend.
Wait, already?
Yeah, I said that earlier.
Yeah.
Wait, what the fuck?
Is that not the jungle that we went through?
That has to be the jungle, right?
It is, but I think there's way more of the jungle.
Oh, maybe...
I've explored all the jungle already.
Oh my God, all of it?
I hear the wild whispers of the dazzling leap.
Leap.
I'm in the jungle.
Whispers of a leap?
What the hell are you talking about?
Do you think if we do the mini-game again, it unlocks the jungle?
Oh, maybe.
Wait, hold on before you do.
Yeah, I'm like...
How do I do this?
I'm in the jungle too.
Oh, I'm in the...
Wait, where's the famous water area for the jungle?
Oh, I found the famous tree!
Wait, are you in the...
The famous Lion King tree.
There's no famous tree.
No, if you don't know...
Oh my God, you're in the gorge.
You want me to...
I'm kinda...
Do you need me to start the game so you can get out of there?
I don't know how to get out of here.
I don't know how to use the power-up.
Use your wand!
Wait, really?
Wait, no, I think that takes you out.
You won't return to...
Yeah, that takes you to the hub.
Wait, if you left-click it though, you get other stuff.
Wait, no you don't.
Oh wait, you do.
Oh, it's the mini-game.
It teleports to the...
Yeah, it teleports to the mini-game.
Wait, it's the jungle!
I teleported to the jungle!
Oh, I can do that too!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Use your magic wand!
Alright.
Alright, let's catch some grub.
Alright, we got this.
We're like so much better now.
Yeah, yeah.
Right-click, right-click.
Interact with them.
Alright, we're better than them.
We're literally them, but we're better.
That's mine.
Oh, I got Minecraft music again.
No, no, no!
Bitch!
We're a team!
What do you mean, bitch?
I wasn't talking to you!
I was talking to actual Pumbaa!
I am actual Pumbaa, what do you mean?
I am him.
Oh no, he took...
Oh, there's a beetle.
That's right, we're faster than you.
We're better than you.
I'm getting so many points.
Me too.
We have 60...
Oh my god, we're 65.
We're literally gonna starve them to death.
We are sweeping, we are sweeping.
No, Pumbaa!
Third time's the charm.
They're gonna starve.
We're gonna eliminate the entire bug population in the jungle.
Yeah, they'll have nothing.
They'll have nothing.
Come on, let me get that one.
The mighty jungle flies loose tonight.
Oh my god, we're at 103!
Alright, we did it.
We've explored the jungle.
We got outgrubbed by the rookies.
That's right!
Get outgrubbed!
Yeah, this is what I have to say about that.
What did I say?
Transformers, roll out.
You've become the size of Jabo.
Autobots, roll out.
Roll out.
Alright, okay.
Wait, follow me though, follow me.
Oh, I'm following you?
Oh wait, do you want to go talk to them?
And I'll try and get the other stuff in the jungle.
No, you just TP.
With your magic wand.
No, there's more back here.
There's more back here?
Yeah, why do you think I fell into the gorge?
But what does that mean?
It's not gonna progress the story.
I don't know, let's go talk to them.
Oh see, it's the famous bridge.
It's the Lion King bridge.
Oh, this is when they go...
No, it's Hakuna Matata.
Oh yeah, it's Hakuna Matata.
I wish I could push you off.
Wait, you want to see something really dramatic?
No!
Simba.
Remember who you are.
Wait, can I die in here?
I wonder.
I'm gonna try and drown myself.
Let's see what happens.
Remember who you are.
Wait, wait, wait, before we die.
I'm dying and I'm...
I'm dying while I emote.
Wait, I'm healing at the same time though.
Wait, you're right.
Oh, I think we're on this cause...
Wait, no, no, we can out-damage the heals.
I'm dying!
Oh, we're back home.
We're back in the jungle.
Oh, we're back in the jungle.
Back home.
I don't want to live here.
I don't understand.
Why won't it let us get out?
Wait, there's more to the jungle.
There's a pathway here.
Have you been listening to anything?
Hey look, there's the famous Lion King bridge.
It's a fucking groundhog day.
Yeah, we're restarting the day cause we died.
I'm like going deep in the jungle.
I think I...
I don't want to live in Pride Rock anymore.
But wait, I'm hitting...
I'm hitting the invisible wall though.
I don't understand.
We did...
Oh, is it cause we talked to Timon and Pumbaa too fast?
The game was like you were not supposed to talk to them yet.
Oh, maybe.
Or is this the jungle?
Wait, there's a black zebra.
Oh, it's just a gazelle.
Oh my God.
Wait, aren't zebras originally black with white stripes?
I remember, somebody like shaved...
They like...
They're like...
They shaved a zebra and they're like...
The stripes, the white stripes are the fur.
Why are you laughing?
It's true!
Why?
They are!
Why are you laughing?
Wait, I'm stuck behind an invisible wall.
I think I'm...
I think I'm trapped for real.
It's alright.
Just use your magic wand.
I got it.
Okay, I'm out.
Use your magic wand.
Are you gonna go talk to...
Yeah, I'll talk to them again.
I think we broke the game.
I think we're never gonna see Mufasa die.
What?
They don't think children will sequence break?
Like, come on.
We'll never see Mufasa die.
That's fine.
It's so...
It's like literally the only thing I asked for.
That's...
I know you wanted a brother.
I always wanted a brother.
Just like you.
No!
It's cause we sequence break!
We're never gonna see...
I think so.
We're never gonna see Mufasa die.
I don't think they probably have him die.
I'm pretty sure we could have seen him die.
Like, why would he...
Why would he, like, you know...
He would, like, dissolve into little Minecraft dust particles.
You know, like the Minecraft story where the pig just...
Piggyback.
Have you ever seen a Minecraft...
Infamous Minecraft story from Telltale's game?
Where, like, the pig...
It was, like, an emotional moment.
And then the pig just fucking dies.
And turns into pork.
Wait, you've never seen that video?
Okay, wait.
I'm gonna kidnap a hyena real quick.
I found a hyena.
Oh, where did you find one?
I'm in the hyena territory.
You know, like...
They're like, the light doesn't touch us.
Don't go there.
I'm there.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, guys.
How do you use this?
Do you know?
I can't believe you've never seen that video before.
It's so good.
I don't consume Minecraft content.
I'm kidnapping this hyena.
You're mine now.
How do I get this?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Why would the compass work?
Oh.
I found another thing.
Oh, my God.
I found the hyenas.
I found where they live.
Wait, what the fuck is this?
What's an ability you don't have yet?
Oh.
Oh!
Hello.
Man inside doesn't want to talk to me.
She's too good for me.
Oh, they're all like...
Oh, there's this ability we don't have yet.
Okay, let me send...
I'm gonna send you the...
I'm sending...
Oh, my other game.
Oh, fuck.
Did you...
Did you game crash?
No, I remember what I said every time I tab out.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait.
All right.
I'm in the dressing room so I can show you.
Okay.
Minecraft story pig.
I can't believe you've never seen this before.
It's so good.
It is so good.
It better be.
It's actually...
It's so good.
It's one of the best...
One of the best scenes ever.
I'm kidnapping a hyena.
Are you kidnapping a hyena?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Why is it four minutes long?
Why?
It's four minutes long.
We only have two more hyenas to kidnap.
Okay, wait.
I need to find...
I need to find the shortest video.
I can't...
I cannot watch.
Let's do Markiplier Reacts.
Markiplier Reacts.
I'm gonna kidnap another hyena.
What the hell is that?
Watch this.
Are you in the realm?
Oh, my God.
God damn it.
Okay, I'm back in.
I'm in the realm.
I'm with the hyenas.
Wait, watch the video.
Oh, I just saw you.
I see you.
Wait, you're Steve again?
Oh, am I Steve again?
God damn it.
Let me...
Don't worry.
I'll be Sans.
And then...
Am I Sans?
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, you're Sans.
And then, I'll be...
Pumbaa.
Oh, wait.
There's hyenas.
We can talk to them.
No, they don't talk to you.
They don't acknowledge you.
What?
Bastards.
Okay, you...
Well, well, Banzai.
What have we got here?
Wait, they talk to you?
I don't know, Shinzy.
But I'd say it's trespassers.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait.
We'd love you to stick around for dinner.
You talk to me?
Yeah, maybe we could get those...
Well, you know...
Maybe you need to be more personable.
Oh my god.
I'm Pumbaa.
How much more personable can I be?
I'm rizzing them.
Maybe we could get those little lion cubs we saw to join us if they're lying around.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got one.
Make mine a cub sandwich.
What do you think?
I think I'm hungry.
All this talk of food has me starving.
Oh, me too.
Are you thinking what I'm thinking?
Dinner.
Is that it?
That's all they say?
Ed doesn't say anything.
Oh, Ed just...
That's not fair.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I just had to talk to her.
And then she talks.
You're Steve again.
I'm Steve again?
Yeah, I had to...
I got kicked out and then...
Oh.
Yeah, I tabbed out.
Guys, now I know why people don't play Bedrock.
It doesn't do anything for me.
All right.
You know what?
Wait, should we do...
Let's try to go creative mode.
How do you do that?
I think like...
Return to the hub?
Wait, mode slash...
What's the mode?
Mode...
No, I think I remember.
When you make this, it doesn't allow you to do...
Wait, really?
Yeah, because I tried to add them.
No, wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
Slash...
Oh, I can.
I can.
I think.
Oh, you can?
Slash...
I have to be the operator, right?
What is it?
Mode...
Try, try, try.
What is it?
Game mode.
Game rules?
I don't know how it is on Bedrock.
Wait, what is it?
Slash...
Game mode.
Cheats are allowed.
No!
See, see, see.
Wait, I should be allowed to...
I should be able to edit this.
I think Disney is like...
Disney is like, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Why are you cheating?
No.
You know what?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna teleport to...
I'm gonna go to...
Oh.
Cheats aren't fine and played on me.
Wait, I'm back in the hub.
Where did you go?
I'm in Lion King.
You're still there?
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm here now.
Okay, I'll leave.
Is there nothing else to do here?
Oh, wait.
I can activate cheats?
How?
Wait, I think if we go into sandbox mode, maybe?
Wait, okay, friend...
Oh, I activated friendly fire.
Oh, you did?
Oh, I activated cheats.
Wait, I found the last hyena!
I activated cheats.
Yeah.
Okay, uh...
Game mode...
Creative.
Your game mode has been successfully updated.
I'm flying.
What?
In the jungle...
The mighty jungle...
A lion sleeps tonight.
Where are you?
In the jungle...
The mighty...
Remember who you are.
Where are you?
Are you looking at me?
No, I'm trying to...
Oh, wait, I see you.
I see you.
Remember who you are.
Okay, game mode...
I'm gonna give you...
I'm gonna see if I can give you...
Wait, wait, wait.
Where are you, though?
Where are you?
Just go down.
I don't see you.
Turn around.
In the jungle...
The mighty jungle...
The lion...
I can't hurt you!
This is so fucked up.
The lion sleeps tonight...
Yes!
In the jungle...
I can't go back.
Wait, what happened?
Where did you go?
You like, TP'd me.
Wait, no, I'm still in the jungle.
Wait, can I kill Mufasa?
Are you trying to kill Mufasa?
Wait, can you?
I'll kill him now.
Wait, can you push him?
Can you push him?
No, I'm doing something better.
In the jungle...
The mighty jungle...
Long live the...
Look, he's begging for it.
Long live the king.
He's breaking his neck to get it.
Do it already!
Oh my god, he's invincible!
Wait, with this we might actually be able to push him to the...
To the gorge, and then we can have him actually fall down and die.
Can we push him?
Oh yeah, I definitely could get hurt from that.
How do we push him?
With the water!
Oh, with the water?
Okay, we gotta make a tunnel to it.
Where's the gorge?
It's over this way, I think.
Oh my god, so far.
Oh, we gotta put him in a boat!
Okay, let me get the boat.
Mufasa, we're gonna recreate history.
What's that over there?
Something's glowing.
What is that, you guys?
Oh my god, it's on the boat!
Wait, wait, wait.
Get rid of the...
What the heck?
Oh my god, I gotta get rid of this lava.
Use a bucket, use a bucket.
Oh, this thing.
No, no, no, no.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, I'm stuck, I'm stuck!
Wait, wait, wait, no, no, no!
Stop, stop!
Where did you go?
Oh god, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck!
Use your magic wand, use your magic wand!
I'm trying!
I'm trying not to use it!
Okay, I'm fine.
Are you okay?
I don't think you're fine.
I'm fine, everything's good.
Alright, I'm okay too.
Get in the boat, Mufasa.
Get in the boat.
Oh my god, I think I fucked it up.
No!
Use water to push him in.
He's not getting on the boat, look at all the boats I have.
He's not getting in.
Oh no.
Oh, I got him, I got him in the boat!
He's in, he's in, he's in!
And all it took was for me to show up.
Wait, can I get in the boat?
Alright, it's time.
Here we go, here we go, here we go!
Come on, Mufasa!
Come on, Mufasa, come on!
We've kidnapped the king!
We're gonna finish the job, do something Scar could never do.
Should we bring Scar?
No, he's too far.
What if I bring Simba?
To watch his dad die.
Watch your dad die, Simba, it's time.
It's time.
Wait, I wanna be up higher.
Don't worry, I'm coming over too.
I'm coming over, Simba.
How can we get him up to the top of the gorge?
Oh, the water, I can bring water over.
Oh yeah, bring some water and I'll float up it.
Okay, okay.
Don't worry,
I'm bringing Simba too.
Simba.
I see you very slowly.
Wait, I can leash the boat.
Wait, I can?
Leash.
Wait, can I actually?
Simba.
Can I leash you up?
But you went inside one of these paths, you can't go in here.
Okay, it's time.
You roll, I pour water.
Okay.
Okay,
there we go.
Wait, let's try the leash now.
Maybe it'll work.
Maybe, yeah.
Does it work?
Hold on.
How do I leash him?
I think you leash the boat.
There you go.
No, it doesn't work.
No, no, no, no.
I'll just give you a... No, no, you roll, I water.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I wanna go up higher.
It's time to watch your dad die, Simba.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go to the top of that hill.
Yeah.
Up here.
And let the water run down and see if we can get it up here.
Up here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, come on, Mufasa.
Let's try going up.
The lion sleeps tonight in the jungle.
The mighty jungle...
Mufasa!
Mufasa, too soon!
Too soon, Mufasa!
The mighty jungle...
Stop sending water!
The mighty... The lion sleeps tonight...
Not yet!
I want him to fall from the absolute tallest spot.
You gotta roll up.
I'm trying!
Oh my...
I'm putting more water.
No more water!
No more water.
Oh god.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Oh gosh, I was so close.
At least it didn't work, you guys.
Oh, I'm close.
I'm close.
Is he still with me?
No.
The new ocean in the Sahara.
Get rid of some of the water!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We're creating an ocean in Africa.
Simba.
Long live the king.
Why am I going down with him?
Long live the king!
You see that, Simba?
You see that?
You see your dad killed your dad.
Remember these faces.
Timon and Pumbaa.
Killed your dad.
Killed your dad so now you can be your gay husband.
Gay fathers.
Someone just said try TNT on them.
That's right.
We killed your dad so we can adopt you.
Get the TNT.
Get the TNT and blow him up.
Goodbye, Mufasa.
Wait,
wait, wait.
Can I go to the other side?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pure cinema.
Yeah, pure cinema.
We'll know now.
I'll tell you when I'm there.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let me get to the top.
I'm slow, I'm slow.
It's all the water.
This movie is different from what I remember.
We're doing what Scar couldn't.
From Timon and Pumbaa.
Okay.
Light her up.
I lit it up.
He lived!
Oh my god, he lived!
I thought it would like shoot him up into the air.
Yeah, me too.
I thought so too.
Oh man.
Well, that was great.
It was great visiting Lion King.
Yeah.
Now I'm gonna burn the forest.
Oh shit.
Wait, there's water.
There's water.
Wait, where's the water?
I'm burning Africa down.
Goodbye, planes.
Oh my god, they're just walking right through it.
Goodbye.
Wait, these aren't even real trees.
They're not even...
They don't even light up.
Wait, they're not even real trees.
Where are we?
Oh yeah, this is apparently a dream.
This is Disney magic.
We're in Simba's nightmare right now.
This is what he replays, except he remembers his dad died.
But it also includes fire all around.
Fire and Timon and Pumbaa.
I can reset the world so we can do creative one versus the other ones.
Okay.
Alright, let me reset the world.
It's like nothing happened.
It's like we didn't terrorize the planes.
I'll reset the world.
Wait, get out of the world.
I'll reset it.
Hold on.
Are you enjoying Minecraft?
Wait, so like leave, leave?
Yeah, leave, leave and I'll reset it.
Let's see, how do I destroy this?
Okay.
Okay, manage realm.
Oh my god, wait, how do I...
Guys, this is my first time going through this.
Yeah, this is Kingdom Hearts 4.
Alright, let's see.
How do I destroy this world as if nothing happened?
As if we didn't kill everything.
Disactivated.
Wait, can you just make a new realm?
Yeah, I could.
I want to destroy this realm though.
I don't want this realm anymore.
Oh wait, it's here.
You discovered the Badlands.
I assumed that was...
I assumed that one was like...
Yeah, that one's our realm.
How do I destroy you?
I want to destroy.
Okay, edit world.
Fetching realm.
Oh, I can restore the world!
To what it was like.
I don't want to restore.
I want to destroy it.
Fetching realm...
I'm trying to figure it out!
Why doesn't it let me destroy you?
Okay, create new.
Okay, play on realms.
Here.
I did it.
I'm destroying the realm as if it never happened.
What we did...
It's like we never terrorized this area.
Delete the vod.
Yeah, we didn't try to kill Mufasa.
We didn't.
I'm gonna change.
No one will know my crime.
I'm a solid creeper.
No one will know.
I don't know why I have these.
I didn't buy them, so I don't know why I have them.
Oh, solid creeper?
Yeah, I recreated it.
Alright.
Oh, you did?
Send me in.
Wait, add realm members.
Invite.
There you go, did you get it?
Let me see.
Yeah.
Alright.
It's like...
We didn't destroy this realm.
It's like we never...
Wait, I love...
Wait.
I'm gonna be a new skin.
You're gonna be a new skin?
Bonjour, Mephisele.
This is a great pride.
Do the Tetris.
Okay.
Okay, I wanna be Disney too.
Let's see.
It is a great pleasure.
Oh wait, I can change the set.
Wait, let me add...
What is it?
Red leaf fire.
Okay.
Oh, did I not save it?
Red leaf fire.
A beast!
Oh my god, it's a beast!
Unlock all worlds, alright.
Unlocked all worlds.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's going beast mode!
Oh god, which is that?
Oh my god, we unlocked everything.
Aladdin!
This is the record book.
Why is it successfully executed?
Do you have that successfully executed six function entries?
Do you have?
Oh my god, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
This is a successfully...
I thought it was because I was...
On my chat.
I thought it was because...
Oh, function six is clocking someone in the face?
Oh, it's because I hit you.
That's why I have it.
You hit me, I hit you too much.
Oh, I have all the game info on?
How do I turn that off?
They're not all unlocked.
Yeah, they are.
That's weird.
They should be.
What is this?
Oh, shit, sorry.
Where are we?
Oh, we're in the breeze!
The breeze!
Oh my god, it's Gusto!
Oh, game.
Oh, it's because I had this.
Game rule.
It's because I had that.
Oh my god, what did I do?
Oh my god!
I broke my game.
What did I do?
What did you do?
I broke my game.
I'm trying to fix my game right now.
No, stop!
I broke my game!
If you die, you might live.
You might be back to normal.
No, that's not how it works!
No!
I broke my game!
Lumiere!
No!
Stop!
Are you dying at all?
No, I don't know.
I'm trying to fix my game right now.
Chat, I can't.
No, I still can't get out.
Somebody fix my chat!
What are you talking about?
My chat, it's broken!
Somebody fix my chat!
All I see is the game rules!
What did I do?
How did this happen to me?
I'm going to kill you!
Don't worry!
Don't worry, you'll die!
You'll die and then you'll be reborn!
Don't worry, it's working!
Don't worry, I'll kill you!
I'll kill you!
Did it work?
You saw nothing.
No!
The beast!
It didn't work.
I don't know what's going on.
All I see is my chat.
My chat commands.
That's all I see!
Did you try escape?
Did I try escape?
There you are!
You look capable!
Join me!
We're going to storm the castle and slay the hideous beast!
Did he actually say that?
Oh my god, but you're the beast!
I know!
So we can rescue the girl!
Who's going to be my wife!
The most beautiful Belle!
It will be your honor!
A mighty honor, I'd say!
Yes, LeFou, very mighty!
Meet me at the edge of the village.
We'll set out from there, onward!
Yeah, onward!
Oh my god, did we get to kill Gaston?
Oh my god, are we going to kill him?
Bye, Gaston!
Goodbye!
Wait, what if I restart my game?
Will it fix everything?
I'll fix you.
What I see is like...
I can't see half my screen.
That's...
I don't know when I broke the game.
I thought this was blood.
I thought this was blood spots.
Bonjour!
I need six eggs!
That's too expensive!
It must be worth it in provincial life!
That's what I'm going to make of my life!
Guys, it didn't work.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he looks like...
Wait, where are you?
I'm at the edge of the village.
Oh, I'm heading over there.
It looks like...
I'm gonna go into Belle's room and sniff her sheets.
You're gonna what?
What are you gonna do?
Where are you?
I'm trying to fix my game.
Still?
I don't understand, it's so bad.
She's the most beautiful girl.
You have to.
You only get one chance to do that.
Can I ride the horse?
Please, somebody...
Free me!
Here, once you're good...
I have a...
I have a ride for us.
Wait, are you in Belle's house?
I'm...
Are you in here?
I'm heading over to Belle's house right now.
I see Belle's dad.
Yeah, that's Belle's dad.
Wait, where are you?
I do not see you.
Wait, I got a collectible.
I do too.
I already got that.
Wait, where are you?
I'm right in front of Belle's house.
They got another...
Command rule for me to try out.
Why is this so scuffed?
You have to see what I have to go through.
Your game is cursed.
Wait, I think it's fixed.
No, it's not.
I still don't see you.
I fixed it!
It's fixed!
Oh my god, I get to see my screen!
Oh my god!
Okay, we figured it out.
I'm with a horse right now.
Wait, where are you?
I'm in front of Belle's house.
I'm in front of Belle's house too.
Hello?
You're here.
The beast?
Okay, do you see Belle's dad?
I'm at the village farm.
Sorry, I'm not at her house.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, you're so far.
Where are you?
I'm gonna head over to Belle.
Okay, head over to Belle's dad.
Belle's dad?
Yeah, we gotta go talk to Gaston.
Oh, I see him!
Oh, I see you!
Hello Steve.
Wait, am I Steve?
Yeah.
Don't worry, the sign's gonna be here for a sec.
And then...
There we go.
Bonjour.
Mademoiselle.
What does Belle's dad say?
I don't know, I didn't talk to him.
I'm gonna talk to him.
Oh no, how on earth did that happen?
I'm about ready to give up on this hunk of junk.
I'll never get this bone-headed contraption to work.
That's all he says.
Oh, alright, goodbye.
Of course, Lumiere.
Alright, I'll be...
Look, this time we're not gonna sequence break.
So we're gonna experience the story.
I'll be in the fall.
Oh, we can't leave just yet.
First I must go take care of old Maurice.
You go ahead and scout for us.
And then soon I will have Belle for my wife.
Make no mistake.
Oh, you don't get a lot.
Just like the real Maurice.
Let's take the horse.
Alright, but I can't ride the horse with you.
You can't?
Can I?
No, I can't.
We gotta get another horse.
Wait, there's another horse over there.
I saw another horse that we can steal.
This is the way to the castle.
Oh yeah, I see your horse.
Yeah, that's my horse.
You thought this was her dad?
Yeah, I thought that was her dad.
I was like, there's the dad.
With beautiful red luscious hair.
Totally what Belle is known for.
Red luscious hair.
Yeah, yeah.
She got the brown hair from the mom.
Wow, there's so many...
Wait, I'm going the right way, right?
I don't know, I'm looking at the map right now.
We're at the forest hills.
That should be the way.
Oh, there it is!
The castle!
Oh, daddy's home.
Why are you in the ground?
The beast's castle.
There's Belle over there.
We did it, Gaston.
We killed the beast.
We did it.
The beast is down.
You can't be creative for a second.
Just use your magic wand.
Right click.
Do you want to return to the hub?
No, left click, left click.
Just TP to Belle.
TP to the castle kitchen.
No, I don't want to...
Wait, hold on.
I'll be there.
Oh my god, there's me.
There's tiny.
Hold on.
Wait for me.
We did it, everybody.
We killed the beast.
Kill the beast.
No, not me.
You got the wrong guy.
I'm his brother.
You always wanted a brother.
Can you bring your horse back?
So I have a horse to...
I have to ride the horse back to you.
What do I do?
Just run.
There's gotta be like a third horse.
Just get over here.
I'm trying.
Am I going the right way?
I think there might be another way.
Just open your map.
What's up?
I'm going towards a mysterious path.
What the fuck do you mean a mysterious path?
Literally, the next thing is Belle.
I've always wanted a brother.
Couldn't Disney have paid for properly looping music in this game?
I don't understand.
They could've literally just made like Minecraft music of the soundtrack.
I see your name.
I see you too.
This is like copyrighted Minecraft Beauty and the Beast music.
Yeah.
It's like just legally distinct.
I just got someone with a really interesting name super chatting me.
What is it?
And I want you to confirm or deny.
Eating Doki Bird's ass.
They gave you money and not me?
They're too busy eating your ass.
Look, look, there's me.
Oh my god.
I'm going to stand next to you and you won't know who's who.
Who's who?
Oh wait, I actually thought you were...
Who's so right, Lumiere?
Oh my god.
Wait, can I ride that?
Oh my god, there's a dresser.
You're Sonic running?
Yeah, I'm Sonic.
You can't ride the star.
I'll be Lumiere.
Yeah, you be Lumiere.
Gasp, do my eyes deceive me or do we have a guest?
Oh, you must be soaked to the bone.
Please, please come in.
You hear me, Cogsworth?
Oh.
Lumiere, what are you doing?
We can't let them go back out there.
Please, you must stay.
Be our guest.
He said the thing!
No, no, no.
The master won't like this at all.
Oh, Cogsworth, have a heart.
Of course, they are welcome here.
Now, let us introduce you to our other esteemed guest.
Mademoiselle Belle.
She is just over there.
Where?
What does that mean?
She is under there.
Wait, I think she's at the kitchen.
Yeah, there she is.
They put the woman in the kitchen?
Damn.
She's flexing on us.
Wait, I think it's a minigame.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Be our guest.
Put our service to the...
Oh, you can be Mrs. Potts.
I bet you'd like a nice spot of tea.
It'll warm you up in no time.
Oh, that's all she says.
Hey, wanna see me do a trick?
Oh my god, look how tiny he is.
And he does a flip.
What are you talking about, mama?
What's going on?
That might not be a cool trick, but can you do this?
Yeah.
I'm gonna talk to Belle.
Oh, hello.
It's very nice to meet you.
Are you a guest here as well?
Oh, I see.
Gaston has sent you to rescue me, has he?
Of course he'd never ask me what I want.
Well, you can tell him I'm not in any danger.
Though I doubt he'd listen.
Pardon me, Belle.
I don't think we can finish your surprise dinner in time.
Our ideas may have been a bit ground.
We would need more help in the kitchen.
Oh, and do we have another guest?
Yes.
I'd hope they'd join us.
Oh, but you're right.
It is getting awfully late.
Hmm.
I think I have an idea.
What if I help as well?
I've read through the recipe book after all.
Oh my god.
Perhaps you could help us too.
We could really use another pair of hands.
I could read out the instructions while you help with the preparations.
Oh boy, we're good at that.
Oh yeah, we're so good at reading instructions.
It's not like we just sequence break the last one.
The horse just walked in.
He's like, I'm hungry.
Oh my god.
How hungry.
Alright, yeah, let's cook a meal.
Wonderful, let's get started.
Okay.
Belle will tell you what to cook.
Why does she keep flexing on us?
I know, what is she doing?
I don't understand.
She's styling on us.
Tell you which ingredients.
Go into the recipe.
Then you can prepare them and place them on the dishes.
Use ingredients on cooking.
What the hell, is this overcooked?
Yeah, I was thinking too.
Oh god.
Lumiere will be waiting to take the plates to the dining room.
Oh my god.
Okay, we can do this.
Do they need to eat their inanimate objects?
Yeah, but Belle needs to eat.
Oh no, first, shall we...
This calls for baked cheese.
Where's cheese?
Okay, and put it in the oven.
Why does the master have to make food?
You put it in the oven.
Yeah, that's the oven, right?
That looks like an oven.
Oh my god, it's actually playing the song!
Wait, is it?
Wait, I wanna hear it.
Oh, it is!
What do we do with this?
Wait, I think it shows us up here.
Oh, and then...
Oh, we're supposed to...
She makes...
Oh, this is fun!
What do I do?
Oh my god, some cheese for you!
I did it!
Oh my god!
Grab an apple and combine it with the wheat.
I'm already doing it!
Did you get the wheat?
Wait, we do our own thing.
Are we competing?
Oh, we are!
We're
working together!
Oh my god, there's two voices!
I'm too distracted.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, okay.
Did that work?
That's a person.
Oh my god, that's messed up.
Wait, where's the picture?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, huh?
Where's the...
Oh, here.
Oh, and this.
What am I...
What's the other thing I'm getting?
Oh, spices.
Okay, I got it.
I figured it out.
Wait, you already did it?
Oh my god.
Is that me?
What is that?
I'm not gonna say.
We're competing.
There I say!
That was magical!
That was rather fun.
And we must thank our new friend for the help.
Friend?
Oh my god, look at her hips.
Oh my god.
I can't believe they actually started singing.
It's because you don't have real plates.
And you only use paper plates.
I don't think we could've done it without you.
Doki?
What?
It still keeps going.
Belle keeps talking.
Oh.
Now it's time to end.
But if you'd like to help us practice these recipes again, just let us know.
What is all this?
And what are they doing here?
It's alright.
There's no need to worry.
We are new friends.
Help us prepare this feast.
Are you?
A feast?
For me?
Yes, I wanted to thank you for helping me escape from those wolves.
It was my pleasure.
I was worried about how to invite you to dinner.
Well, I graciously accept.
Shall we eat?
Alright, let's go eat!
Yay!
Oh my god, everybody's here!
Oh my god, what is this?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Hey!
Hey brother!
He's so much bigger than you!
Who's the real beast?
Who could it be?
I want to do something special for Belle.
I've never felt this way about anyone before.
What are we doing here?
What are we doing next here?
Did we just talk to them?
I think this game might have been a scam.
Is that it?
There has to be...
When do we kill the beast?
That doesn't actually happen in the story.
I want to kill the...
Oh, there's the horse!
Our horse went here.
I want to know when we can kill the beast.
Kill the beast!
Does the game part end when we get to the mini game?
Yeah, I think there's like two dialogues and that's it.
Oh my god, we'll never kill the beast.
Where is the horse?
Oh, he's in the library.
He wants to get educated.
Oh, hello.
I got a book.
Wait, there's more here?
Where does this go?
I want to find the beast's...
The beast's room and then destroy his rose.
Yeah, we got to destroy the rose.
Destroy the... I found it!
Wait, wait, wait!
I want to see it!
I found it.
Is it up more?
Yeah, it's up here.
Watch, I'll do something crazy.
No, I see you.
Hold on.
Oh, shit.
Watch.
Do you see this rose?
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh.
I can't destroy it.
There's a watermelon under here!
It's gone now.
What?
And thus the beast shall die.
Why is there a melon?
It's okay.
It's like nothing.
Oh my god, this place is full of cobwebs.
I mean, it is old.
Look, the rose is gone.
I did it.
Whoa.
Yeah, you did it.
I'm proud of you.
We did it.
We destroyed the beast's home.
Land on that...
Did you say hole?
Home.
And thus my job here...
Wait, wait, wait, Min, look.
Look at me.
Where are you?
My job here is done.
I thought you were gonna jump off.
Wait, I wonder...
It's your brother.
Wait, I'm gonna be a gargoyle?
My job here is done.
Do I look good?
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, you look just like him.
Which one's the real gargoyle?
Wait, there's a...
There's a garden in the back.
Wait, is there?
You wanna be creative mode?
Okay, okay, okay.
Game mode, creative...
Wait, what's your...
What's your full name?
MadeMintPhantom, I think.
MadeMintPhantom, creative.
Did you get it?
Oh, I didn't, wait.
How do I give you creative?
Mint...
Game mode...
Creative...
Made...
Oh, here you go.
Here you go.
Yeah!
Now we can zoom everywhere.
What's this?
I think it's a collectible.
You know, silly Belle, leaving her stuff around as always.
Yeah, I'm gonna destroy this castle.
Kill the beast!
I know he's got treasure in the basement!
He's gotta have treasure in the basement!
Oh, the melons are back!
Why is there melons in his home?
Oh, it's like the tiles.
It's the green tiles.
They used melon for it.
Oh...
Alright, I'm going.
Kill the beast!
I'm going into the basement.
Are we bad people?
No...
I'm trying to go...
I'm trying to get into his home.
Maybe they'll have like...
Prisoners down there.
I'm gonna kill Gaston.
Just for the sake of it.
Where are you, Gaston?
I can't believe it, we don't actually get to kill the beast.
What's the point?
Come on, guys.
Torch...
There we go.
We're more villainous than Disney villains.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you're still down there?
Where did you dig to?
Where are you?
Surely there's treasure down here.
Oh my god.
Into the void.
Here we go.
Into the unknown.
Yeah, where's Frozen World?
I found the basement.
Nothing but the abyss.
Into the unknown.
That's where they send the prisoners.
Right here, sir.
This is where they...
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh, there I am.
Can I save my horse now?
I don't know where your horse is.
He's down here.
Oh, there he is.
He's a bit further than before.
I wonder what the collectible is here.
Explore all areas.
Let's find the hidden books.
Oh, we got it.
Oh yeah, we got most of everything.
We basically finished this world.
I'm going back to the hub.
I'm just exploring a little bit.
I don't think there's anywhere to explore.
This is where like...
This is the edge of the world.
Who the hell is this farmer?
I'm gonna burn the village.
Burn Gaston.
I'm coming back.
Lumiere.
I'm Alter Lumiere.
I'm here to burn the village.
You try to kill the beast, I'll kill the world.
Hold on.
I can send him.
Please.
Oh shit.
I know how to kill Gaston.
Wait, what?
What are you doing?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, he has a task for us.
Why does he have an excavation point?
No, he doesn't.
It was just going to the beast.
Okay, it's time.
We know how to kill Gaston.
Let's go.
Wait, I can't see anything.
We know what to do now.
I'll go down first.
And then, I believe you're here.
And I'll dig up with you.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Goodbye, Gaston.
Don't worry.
He's so dreamy, Gaston.
Rest in peace.
I went down your hole.
I chose the wrong hole.
Goodbye, Gaston.
There he goes.
We could send the whole village down there.
We kidnapped all the villagers.
And just put them into the void.
What are you doing?
Can you do this?
Wait.
What are you doing?
Can we TP all?
TP all?
TP all NPCs?
Is that TP...
So cute.
This is where he went.
TP...
Uh...
TP... Oh my God.
I know there's one where you can actually...
At all entities.
Oh my God!
You're gonna break the game real.
Did I do it?
Did I break the game?
Wait, where are we?
Where are you?
Did I break the game?
I think I broke the game.
I did it!
I
did it!
Dude,
where are you?
I see you.
What happened?
How did we get here?
I snapped the story...
I snapped the story and...
The beast is no more.
What is that?
Let me change my clothes to fit the setting.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Don't look.
I'm dressing for the occasion.
Me too.
Which one are you gonna be?
Don't wear my same outfit, okay?
Okay.
Alright, I'm turning around.
Where are you?
Alright,
let's go commit some wishes.
Why is this world's volume so much louder?
Wait, we can go get all the treasure!
Oh true!
Oh my god!
Let's free ourselves!
We don't need Aladdin!
We can free ourselves!
Alright, let's go.
We have what we call...
Creative mode.
Woah!
We're rich!
Oh my god!
Abu, don't touch it!
Don't touch the stuff.
Don't touch it, Abu.
Oh my god.
We can be Aladdin.
And then I'll break this.
Yeah, break that.
You can't break it.
We can send it to the unknown.
Into the unknown!
Can your friend do this?
Bomb, bomb.
Can your friend do that?
Can your friend do this?
That's the thing they had!
Why can't we go into the hole?
There we go.
Alright, here we go!
Into the unknown!
Oh my god, how fast have you dug already?
We're free!
We don't need Aladdin!
Aladdin will never get this now.
That's right.
We're not chained to nobody.
We're free genies now.
We're free genies.
We're so stupid.
I know.
I'm breaking out of here.
I'm digging up.
We're digging up!
Okay, that's better.
I'm not gonna be trapped here.
I'm outside of bounds.
Wait, don't dig up.
Wait, I'm right here.
Wait, there's an invisible wall.
There's an invisible wall!
Can we break it?
Oh, I broke it.
That's right.
Nothing can block us.
We're invincible now!
We're all powerful genies!
Where's the sultan?
I'm gonna kidnap the sultan.
Give us the throne!
Or we'll send you to the void.
Oh, he's crying.
He's crying.
He is?
He's gonna do like a thing.
Look, look, look.
He's like, that's right, be afraid.
Wait, what if I do this?
Watch this.
Give us the throne or I'm gonna shoot.
I can't...
That's right.
Give us the throne or I'll shoot.
What?
Alright, sultan.
What are you doing?
I'm poisoning him.
Oh my God.
I'm poisoning the throne.
Wait, go out of creative.
Okay, okay.
See if it works.
Game mode adventure.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, it doesn't work?
No.
What the hell?
No, he didn't poison me.
No!
I've been lied to.
Oh, you know, it's like, one thing I'm...
Wait, what was it?
One thing I pride myself on, I'm an excellent judge of character.
Somebody said?
Yeah.
That's right.
There's nothing inside.
Where did you go?
I don't know.
I'm looking for Jafar.
I wonder if the cast...
Stop!
What is the tiger's name?
Oh, I forgot.
Wait, where did you go?
I'm outside.
Are you with Jasmine?
No, I think she's at the beginning.
No, she's right here.
Oh, where?
Oh, wait, there's a magic carpet.
I'm at the...
No, no, no.
I'm right here.
Where's the tiger?
Over here.
Someone says Raja.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Oh my God, he's so cute!
Hello, Raja.
Alright, show me Jasmine.
Okay, she's like...
Call me Gelatin.
Have you ever seen that song?
That's Aladdin and Jasmine.
Let me break this invisible wall.
Wait, how do we...
Why is there an invisible wall?
I guess we're not allowed to fly.
Wait, how do we access this?
I think we have to talk to Jasmine back there to access this.
Let me talk to her.
Alright, Jasmine.
We need you to head over there so we can activate your game.
Okay, game mode.
Adventure.
Where's Aladdin?
Welcome to Agrabah, my name's Jasmine.
You haven't seen my name, Aladdin, right?
The magic carpet droops down sadly.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, I see her, I see her.
She's already here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A whole new world!
I'm gonna stay in adventure.
Alright, activate the game.
Where's Aladdin?
Oh, that does...
That guy is blonde with blue eyes.
I don't think he belongs here.
Are you lost, buddy?
Alright, I'm talking to Jasmine.
Okay.
Alright, hey you scoundrel.
Did you just steal that apple?
Of course not, we're only talking.
The scoundrel probably ate it, no one steals from my car.
Thief!
Alright.
Ride on the magic carpet to escape from the angry shopkeepers.
You will need to steer in the right direction.
Wait, are we both on the magic carpet?
No, I just...
Wait, I think it's a one-person game.
Wait, is this a one-person?
It doesn't reach the end to win?
Wait, are you racing?
You see this instruction?
I only...
I had to, like, zoom through the text.
Oh, no, I think...
Wait, I'm stuck in the loading screen.
Yeah, me too.
I think we broke the game.
Is our Disney tour over?
Because we didn't properly load into this world.
We deleted the piece.
We deleted the castle.
What do we do?
I want to ride the magic carpet.
No, I want it to be a whole new world.
Here, let's quit.
I'm going to quit.
And I'm going to join again.
Yeah, me too, me too.
We just want to go to a whole new world.
I want to ride the magic carpet.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
Wait, what's happening?
I got the obstacle.
I'm back here.
Wait, okay, I'm in game mode.
Maybe we have to be on adventure, both of us.
I'll give it to you.
Oh, wait, there's Abu.
Are you in the mini game?
No, no, no, no.
I'm in.
Wait, are you in the lobby?
I just discovered a secret room.
Oh, wait, where are you?
Oh, you just trapped me!
I was like,
far beneath the ground.
Okay, okay, I'm good, I'm good.
Okay, where are you?
Is that you?
Are you holding a book?
Yeah, I'm holding a book, where did you go?
You're invisible to me!
Oh,
a magic trick.
Look at this magic.
Wait, can you go into spectator mode?
Can you put us both in spectator?
Okay, okay, okay.
I need to show you.
Okay, okay.
Why are we invisible?
It's like a magic trick.
Okay, now go below.
And then you see the two hidden rooms.
What is this doing here?
Why is there a random fucking room?
Why did you trap me?
It was literally my grave.
What the fuck?
Good.
Wait, I see the blonde man!
Where is he?
I don't think the game is any better.
I think it's still messed up.
I think we messed up.
Put us back to adventure.
And then we'll...
And we can just take us back to the hub.
Okay, okay.
Adventure.
Okay, and then...
I don't know what happened to him.
He just disappeared.
Disappeared.
Where did you go?
Are you going back to the hub?
Yeah, I want to go back to the hub.
We're stuck in the game.
I'm starting the game.
Wait, how do you start the game?
We broke the game.
We actually broke the game.
We're never supposed to be here.
Wait, is that you?
Did you see a flybook?
I see a magical path.
We broke the game.
We were supposed to ride on the magic carpet.
They didn't give us a magic carpet.
I've been slowed.
What do you mean you've been slowed?
Apparently, if you hit a wall, you get slowed.
How did you get a magic carpet?
I don't know.
I'm running the course.
No!
Wait, what's happening?
I can't move.
We're starting the race!
Guards arrived?
What does that mean?
I don't know.
Are we on a carpet?
I think we're just running.
I'm just running.
Be careful.
I made it.
I ran through the one hole I dug.
I ran through the one hole I dug in the invisible wall.
That's why they lost the theory.
No, that's not what happened.
Why?
It's not fair.
Wait, if I right click the carpet, I can have the carpet?
Wait, are you on the carpet?
I had to right click the carpet?
I was just walking.
I'm doing this again.
I literally watched you drop the carpet and keep going.
What?
I'm on a carpet now.
I dropped it.
Why is it so slow?
It's so slow!
I don't think you can touch anything with it.
Or rather, you can't press space or...
Bro, why am I so slow?
Oh god, I'm crying.
I can't see the tracks between my tears.
I don't know.
I'm so confused.
Why am I walking?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we did it.
We're so good at this game.
Oh my god.
We can talk to the carpet.
Yeah, he just restarts the world.
Why?
Where's Aladdin in all of this?
I don't know.
We saw his monkey.
We saw Abu.
We saw... We didn't see Jafar though, but where the fuck is... Where the fuck... In Agrabah, there's no Aladdin?
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Where are we?
We're on the racetrack.
Wow.
I think we actually destroyed... Wait, I'm gonna check if Belle's world is still back.
I'm TP-ing back.
I need to know.
Okay.
Oh, I broke all the portals.
Wait, what do you mean you broke all the portals?
Wait, wait, come back.
None of the portals.
Teleport to one of the mini-games.
Let's go to... Let's go to Maze Chase.
They kicked us out.
I think they closed the portals.
They can't stop us.
It's time to change clothes.
They thought closing the portals will stop us.
They really think you can't stop us from coming here.
We'll always find a way.
Why did you die?
Yeah, you fucked it in two hours, but Organization 13 couldn't do.
Just get us in.
Kingdom Hearts will finish.
We don't even have Kingdom Hearts 4.
The game will finish in Kingdom Hearts 1.
We will kill Sora.
Where are you?
I'm right behind you.
You're invisible to me.
No, you're not invisible.
Wait, maybe if I change skins...
Do you see Sans?
I just hit you.
Oh, yeah, I see you.
Alright,
hello.
Alright, let's go talk to Alice.
Wait, Autobot.
Autobot.
Wait, Autobot, you're right.
Alright, do you like my bow?
Yeah.
To a shark cat with a gun.
This feels on brand for the Mad Hatter.
Yeah, it does.
A very unbirthday to you.
To you.
So, when I was in grade school, no, middle school...
Also, why is the music in here so intense?
But when I was in middle school, I wanted to be the Mad Hatter for my school's Halloween.
Yeah.
And why'd you leave?
Oh, wait, I tabbed out.
And so, my mom got me a costume, but it was one of those sexy costumes that said like...
Oh, my God.
His hat said 69 over 420.
Am I a shark cat or am I Steve?
You're Steve.
Okay, I gotta re-wear my clothes again.
I didn't know what it meant until my mom, or not my mom, my teacher told me what it meant.
Wait, if it's a sexy costume, then wouldn't it be sexy?
I wore a tank top and stuff underneath it, so nothing would show.
Alright, ever since I arrived... Okay, you can be Alice.
Hello, I'm Alice.
I do hope you're someone who is sensical.
Ever since I arrived here, so much has been nonsense.
Oh, but you do seem as though you are what you are rather than being not what you are not.
Perhaps you might help me.
I fear I may have angered the queen.
You see, she sent her playing card guards... Oh, my gosh.
That is so hard to say, playing card guards.
...to chase me through this maze.
Would you help me find a way out?
Oh, thank you.
Quick, we must find an exit.
Alright, what do we do?
Okay, collect paint.
Wait, the leaves are disappearing.
Yeah, I know the leaves... Wait, how are we gonna do the maze if the leaves are disappearing?
Wait, paint the roses to unlock the path.
Avoid the card soldiers, okay?
Okay.
Wait, this is scary.
Yeah, this is scary.
What if they jump scare us?
Get to the end to win... Why are the leaves disappearing?
Did somebody paint the roses already?
Let me make sure...
Wait, oh, we're competing!
SimWonderland...
Wait, oh, did I not get the paint?
Oh, you have to right-click the paint.
Someone was listening, dude.
You just have to... Oh, my God, they're coming.
We're not competing.
Yes, we are.
We have the same score.
Because we haven't found the exit yet.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
I know where you are, Sonic.
Wait, where did I go?
Do you just paint any rose?
I'm so confused.
I guess so.
This is kind of weird.
I don't know where I am.
There's no more paint!
They're only chasing after me!
This is messed up.
I beat the game.
Wait, what?
Where are you?
Oh, there's more paint.
Where did I go?
Oh, no!
I broke the game.
You did it.
I made it out!
I actually...
Wait, no, no.
I'll give you a creative move.
I'll show you where I went.
Okay, okay, okay.
I was like, how did I get here?
I actually...
I actually won the game.
Okay, come here.
Follow me.
I'm breaking this wall.
Oh yeah, break it, break it.
Break the wall.
Okay, okay, watch.
Okay, so...
I...
I ran this way.
So, obviously, we have to go here, right?
This is where we have to go.
But, like, I went...
Watch, follow me.
I went this way.
And then there was a hole right here.
And...
You went through here.
And then I was like...
And then I went all the way...
Follow me.
I went all the way...
I was like...
Wait...
I did it.
And I was like, wait, this is a secret.
I don't think...
Why would they even let you in here?
I don't know.
I clearly was, like, running through this black maze.
And I was like, oh my god, I did it.
I was like...
Why did it go black?
I was so confused.
Let me in.
I didn't realize...
I was not even in the game anymore.
Why is it so intense?
She's like, off with their heads.
Wait, the flower area is so cute.
Oh, yeah, it is.
Oh, you can talk to the flowers.
You can learn a lot of things from the flowers.
Oh, especially in the month of June.
Afternoon.
Where are you?
We're like, I'm in the garden.
I'm trapped, okay.
Wait, where are the flowers?
I wanna talk to the flowers.
I wanna see what they look like.
Oh, there they are.
Yeah, yeah, they're cute.
Look at them.
What else is there?
Oh, where's the Mad Hatter place?
Oh, you're right.
Where is...
Oh, there's Alice.
Alice.
Did I find them?
I found...
Oh, I found it, I found it, I found it!
It's a tea party.
It's next to the gardens.
The garden?
What the hell is the gardens?
It's next to the flowers.
Come, look up, look up.
Up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here, look at me, look at me, look at me.
A very warm birthday to you.
To you, to you, to you, to you.
Okay, I need to talk.
I wanna know what you're gonna say.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
What did you do?
A table!
You ruined their birthday party!
I
think the whole table was left.
Oh my god!
You ruined their birthday!
I ruined their party!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
Over on his table, it's fine.
It's fine.
You ruined their birthday!
Oh, what a delightful child.
I'm so excited.
You must have a cup of tea.
There we go.
Clean cup, clean cup.
Move down, move down.
Oh my god, that poor Dormouse.
That poor Dormouse.
Where's the Dormouse?
Oh my god, I didn't even see him in there.
You ruined their birthday!
It's his grave now.
This is where he dies.
You don't even see him anymore.
Goodbye, Dormouse.
Goodbye, we're sorry.
We're sorry, Menace.
This is why they closed the borders on us.
They can't control my strength.
This is why they closed the borders.
They didn't want us to come back.
The other world heard about us.
Oh, there's... what's his name?
Yeah, with the seashell people.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where are the little children that he enslaved?
Okay.
Oh, look.
Oh, there's the... wait, there's the door.
Wait, is this the door?
What door?
This is where... oh, I'm late, I'm late!
I'm so late!
Oh my god, I broke the door.
Where are you?
Wait, wait, wait, where are you?
I'm still by the tea house.
Float up, float up.
Floating up.
Float up.
And then you'll...
Go to the green forest.
Wait, where are you?
Green forest.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, I see you, I see you.
Right here.
Come here.
There's a rabbit.
Oh, he's late for bed, poor thing!
So this was originally like...
All blocked up and I just fucking destroyed it.
I was like...
It's my world now.
Oh, we can float and everything!
I think that's how you start the world.
Until we broke it.
Yeah, I think we fall down here.
And then we're gonna be like...
Before they closed the borders, we were supposed to...
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
That's right.
We're here to invade your land.
They're like, oh god, don't get mental.
Shut it out, shut everything down!
I heard they snatched the beast world out of existence.
Wait, if you go back to the beast world, is there anything?
How do we...
Let's try magic wand.
I think I need to be in an adventure mode.
Castle kitchen.
Does it still exist?
What is meadow for?
Wait, uh...
Everybody's gone though.
There's no people.
Wait, they might be in the void.
They might be in the void.
I'm gonna go down.
Wait, they're not.
They're all dead.
I think they're all dead.
I think we killed them all.
No.
Oh my god.
Go to the village.
There's not even the gargoyles left.
Wait.
Now I know why they closed the borders.
Now I know.
There's no one.
No one at all.
Where's the beast?
Oh my god.
Nobody's here.
Nothing is here.
Nothing.
Not even the horses.
Wait.
Horse fell out of the world.
People are falling out of the world.
Everybody got Thanos.
Wait.
Why is this door open?
I don't know.
I don't think it was.
I'm breaking it.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
It's so empty.
Bonjour.
Everybody's dead.
I say bonjour, but no one says bonjour back.
Bonjour.
It's a ghost village.
It's perfect for me.
I'm gonna drown myself here for my sins.
Now I know why they closed the border.
Oh, did you set the village on fire?
Hide the evidence.
We gotta burn down the village.
50,000 people used to live here.
Now it's a ghost town.
Why doesn't it work?
Wait, I don't think you can burn this part of the village.
Damn.
You know, that's a good way to end.
You know, I think this is a good way to...
To call it here.
Yeah, I think so.
You know, we should go to Disney World next.
We won't break Disney World.
We'll do Disney World next time.
Yeah, we'll do Disney World next.
Yeah, we'll do Disney World next time, guys.
What a wonderful Disney adventure, everybody.
We wiped out...
We did what Kingdom Hearts couldn't.
We wiped all darkness away.
We wiped out the Disney World.
I can't believe that everybody is dead.
No wonder we got kicked out to Agrabah.
They ported us to Agrabah after what we did.
They're like, they'll die in the desert.
We did it.
We killed them all.
We killed Belle.
We did it.
We killed Belle and the Beast.
That's right, Gaston.
We did it.
Killed the Beast.
Put me in adventurer mode.
Alright, it's time we do it together.
Yeah.
Alright, for the sins.
For our sins.
Remember what we did, man.
I remember.
You remember.
We should...
I'll never forget.
I'm gonna do a flip.
Do you think we can Tetris?
Do the Tetris?
Wait, can I Tetris even while I fall?
I think you did it.
I think you did the Tetris even while you fell.
Wait, you go first.
Okay, hold on.
I didn't fall very far.
Me too.
Oh, we should've done it in the void.
You know what?
We can go to the void.
Wait, we actually can.
Let's go to the void.
Wait, I'm not dying.
No, we can only die in the void.
Okay.
Yeah, I think it's this way.
I think it's this way.
Yeah, it's this way.
This is how I wanna go.
Via Tetris.
We're going all the way down.
Wait, is that not...
Where is it?
I think we have to go down to go up.
No, I see it.
I found it.
Alright, I remember the hole you've dug.
I remember your sins.
I was just trying to protect the village from Gaston.
Wait, I wanna go to Gaston's hole.
You go to this hole, I go to Gaston's hole.
And then, we'll jump at the same time.
Okay, I believe in us.
Hold on, give me a second.
I gotta run there.
What a way to end it.
Hold on, we saw the horses die.
It said on the side they died out of the world.
Yeah.
I guess everybody else did too.
I think...
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm almost there.
What a way to go.
I'm waiting.
I'm almost there.
Okay.
Ready?
3...
2...
1...
Wait, what's this?
Do you see the minigame?
Respawn.
Wait, wait, wait.
Come to my hole.
I think I found everybody.
Wait, we have to go in creative mode.
We have to go in creative mode.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, are they all...
Are they all in the...
Okay, there.
I gave you creative.
Okay, alright.
Come on.
Oh my god.
No way.
Okay.
Okay, just drop.
Oh my god.
What is this?
It's a party.
And even... I think it's every...
It's every entity.
Because there's the book from the beginning.
And you have to beat all the entities.
And there's the team.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I went through the portal and I broke in the event.
Wait, you were in the portal?
Oh my god.
The portal works.
Go through the portal.
Where did you end up?
It's just back in the town.
No, I'm in Snow White.
Oh my god.
I went to Snow White.
Wow, what a great...
What a way to end the collab.
Next time...
Why it broke?
Yeah, we broke the game.
Everything got jammed up for a year.
Next time we'll go to Disneyland.
Oh man, that was fun, man.
Yeah, that was fun.
That was fun too.
I was like, this is where all the Disney characters go when they die.
Don't let Mint and Toki find you.
You'll be sent to the Shadow Realm every time.
We'll send you to the Shadow Realm.
We'll send you to where the Heartless go.
Someone super chat is like, I'm gonna tell my kids that this was the real Kingdom Hearts.
Yeah, this is the real Kingdom Hearts.
This is how you only make one game for Kingdom Hearts.
We get the job done.
Yeah.
Oh my god, GG's.
We really did do it though.
GG's, Mint.
GG's.
Next time we'll do Disney World and we'll try...
Yeah, you can ride the rides on Disney World.
Yeah, hurry up and play the games at the rides too.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We didn't explore all the worlds, guys.
There's those like Snow White and Little Mermaid, right?
Oh yeah, there's still Little Mermaid.
I forgot about that one.
Yeah.
To be fair, we got the fun ones.
I think we did a pretty good job.
Yeah, who cares about Snow White or Little Mermaid anyway?
Who cares about them?
The water levels always suck and Snow White is a dumb bitch.
Damn, what do you have against Snow White?
What did she do to you?
Her movies are boring.
Movies?
She has one.
Sorry, the next movie, I can already tell.
Oh, there's a live action.
Yeah, to be fair.
Did you hear that live action made a lot of movies?
Made a lot of money, sorry.
A lot of money.
More than Sonic.
The crab one?
Yeah, yeah.
They made more money than Sonic.
No!
I thought you loved that one.
It's only because it's Disney.
That's so true.
No!
I found the hole.
I found the Gaston hole.
Come see what you teleport to.
Alright, it's like gacha.
Yeah, it's like a little gacha that we play.
There it is.
Alright, where am I gonna go now?
Where's the evil queen?
It's not teleporting me.
Oh, I'm in Snow White?
Am I Snow White?
Oh, I am in Snow White.
There's the...
There's the birds.
Oh, I see the dark forest.
Yeah, there's no evil queen.
And there's no place where Snow White dies.
Like, what the hell?
I mean, to be fair, there wasn't even a place for Mufasa to die.
We had to create our own destiny.
No, they had the gorge!
They had the gorge.
We had to create our own destiny.
I see you, I see you.
I found the queen's castle.
Yeah, but she's not in here.
She's like somewhere where she's making the potion, you know?
Oh, the evil area.
Yeah, yeah, the evil lair.
Should I have like a upper room?
Maybe.
We'll never know.
I'm doing spectator mode.
Fuck this.
Game mode, spectator...
I'm finding you evil queen.
Me too, me too, me too.
Okay.
Game mode, spectator...
There we go.
Thank you.
I'm in the castle.
Okay.
Where are you?
Wait, there's a dungeon.
Wait, I found it.
There's a dungeon?
Yeah.
Is she down here?
No, she's not.
But like...
How do you get in here?
I don't know.
I just zoomed.
I know.
There's a dungeon.
Oh, there's a little staircase.
Oh, there is.
X-ray on...
Oh, I found her, I found her!
She's with us?
She's here, she's here, she's here.
Look.
Oh my...
Oh my gosh!
She's with us!
The mirror!
Yeah, the mirror.
Mirror, mirror on the wall.
Who's the dumbest of them all?
He's looking at you.
Dokibo.
GG, Smith.
What a fun...
Okay, GG for real.
Disney adventure that we had.
This was truly an adventure.
Truly an adventure that will tell our children and our children's children and Dragoon's children's children and...
Yeah, this is the real Disney experience.
This is the real Disney experience.
This is the real Kingdom Hearts right here.
Yeah, this is how I remember it actually.
I know, me too.
A flower forest?
Where did Snow White die?
Um...
She died...
Well, she like eats the apple.
And then I think she falls off the cliff.
And then she's put in the glass case.
Oh, I found the mines.
Hi-ho!
Oh my god!
Where after do we go?
We work all day and have no pay.
Hi-ho!
There's words there?
No.
That's how I remember it.
Wait, they...
Why don't they use actual Minecraft like...
Horses.
Where's diamonds?
Where the fuck is diamonds?
They're not making any money.
I like how the little gemmies in this world look like the thing from The Sims.
Oh my god, there they are.
Oh my god, they're huge!
I found the dwarves.
Why are the dwarves as big as Snow White?
Where are they?
Go to the...
Wait, wait, wait.
Slash TP.
Yeah, just TP me.
There, look.
I see a squirrel.
They're just as big...
They're just as big as Snow White.
Holy...
Oh my god, the bird's trying to escape out of fear.
They're like...
Let me out!
Wait, that means...
I was like, why is his nose doing that?
Oh my god, they have different lengths of noses.
Look, it's not about the size of the nose.
It's how you use it.
Which one's the real one?
Wait, he's bigger than you.
Wait, this is the first time he's bigger.
Oh my god!
Yeah, why are the dwarves bigger?
Is it because I'm in the ground?
No, you're...
Oh, wait, wait.
I know, they're still bigger than you.
Where are you?
I'm here.
I'm on...
You're invis...
Oh, wait, wait.
You're invisible to me.
Oh, now.
Are you in the house?
Yeah.
Oh, well.
The bird just opened the door.
No, it's me.
Oh, that's you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're the bird?
No, no, I opened the door and then the bird came in.
This one looked like the bird opened it.
I thought you turned into a bird.
Oh my god, Morty, look, I turned into a bird.
Bird.
I'm Donkey Bird.
Look, Morty, funniest shit in the world.
Okay, I'm gonna... I guess that's it then.
GG.
GG's, man.
Oh, great time.
Next time, let's do this again soon and go to Disney World.
And go to actual Disney World.
Yeah, and then let's not destroy Disney World.
I mean, we could.
We could destroy it.
You know, at the end, when the fireworks go off, we just...
When the fireworks are about to go off, and then put a lot of TNT everywhere.
If we go underground, you think we'll see Walt Disney frozen?
Oh my god, you're right, we'll see Walt Disney frozen in a cryogenic chamber.
We'll find Walt Disney's cryogenic chamber.
Yeah.
GG's, man.
GG's.
I'll see you next week.
Yeah.
Next week?
Don't you remember?
Oh yeah, that's right.
Yeah, surprise.
Next week we have another collab.
Another collab.
With the Sloppy Sisters.
So see you next week, man.
Okay, see you next week.
Bye bye, GG's.
Oh wait.
Hey.
Are you gonna go talk to your chat?
I'm still on screen.
Oh, just really fast.
Just gonna say bye.
Okay.
Oh, you're gonna talk to your chat?
Yeah.
Alright.
I'll say bye.
GG's, bye bye.
Bye bye.
Oh my god, that was fun.
I had a great time.
These Minecraft DLC's are so funny.
But I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching Mint and I explore the Disney World.
Us snapping the... snapping the entire world's existence gun.
There you go.
Alright.
Oh wait, there's Dopey.
But we hope you all had a great time, everybody.
It was so much fun.
It was always fun playing with Mint.
So I had a great time just fucking around.
But yeah, everybody.
I hope you guys have a great time today.
Tomorrow it's Doki and Berto's birthday!
It's Dad's birthday!
I have something special planned on that stream.
So I hope you guys come to his birthday party.
Anyway guys, as always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time.
Bye everybody.
Bye!